Okay, I was obsessed with that interview
about all the skin stuff.
Hyram.
Because hello, I'm trying to maintain
and keep myself together.
I was taking notes.
I always talk about how good you look,
but I have not realized and zeroed in
on how perfect your skin is.
Now please don't flirt with me,
this is a place of work.
Please, Drew Barrymore.
I'm not kidding.
Thank you.
You know, I grew up in Washington State,
so I didn't see the sun for the first 18 years of my life.
Oh, that helps.
But I don't buy expensive stuff,
I always do drug store stuff,
which is why I was so fascinated by Hyram
and what he was saying.
I don't think you need to spend nine billion dollars
on some serum.
And yet, that's about what the skin care industry does.
I mean, I've never done anything to my face
and I would like to try not to,
never say never.
I can never get married again, that's true.
I'll never get married again.
You mean that for reals?
Never!
Okay, now I believe you.
Ever.
Now I believe you.
Never.
But the thing that I do care about
and I do feel is still relevant to my life is the face.
And I don't want...
I know myself, I'm a highly addictive person, Ross.
Oh really?
And I do one injection,
I'm gonna look like Jocelyn Wildenstein by Friday.
Please.
Was there a moment where you made that decision
where you were like,
oh, I could either go this way or that way
because I bet, in like showbiz.
I think because I'm so rebellious
that I saw all of that pressure
and I saw all of those women torturing themselves
to look a certain way
and I thought, you miserable people.
And I just wanted to never be afraid
of what life would do to me.
I probably went to too many opposite extremes,
now I'm boring and safe, and you know, healthy.
But I would love if there was some way
that we could let go
and give in to the ride of life a little bit more.
You know, we're gonna age,
things are gonna go south.
And it's okay, and it's a part of life,
and I feel more human and more vulnerable
every year of my life,
but I also know how to appreciate every year
more and more too.
And I'm a little crazy.
So let's get into the news.
(Ross and audience laughing)
All right, now Ross, I know that you've heard
of ghosting and cuffing.
Yeah, mm-hmm.
By the way, what's cuffing again?
It's like cuffing season
when you start hooking up with people.
Okay, so cuffing is like arm and arm.
Yeah, mm-hmm.
Okay, it doesn't sound like that,
they need a new term.
Okay, so cuffing and couching or cushioning,
ghosting, all right.
I wanted to cushion with someone.
I just wanna sit on a couch and hang out.
'Cause cushioning sounds like you're just hanging out
on a couch, but it's very different than that.
So that's what I asked.
Okay, so cushioning, now describe cushioning.
Well, okay, it's almost like keeping multiple people
on a burner, right?
So you're sort of with one,
you're thinking about that one,
but there's like three or four over here
you could go mingle with.
So they say there's two types of people,
Refinery29, there are cuffers,
who meet a person and just kind of wanna build
with that person,
and then there's a cushioner,
someone who has one person that they're kind of looking at,
but a bunch of different people on the back burners.
Okay.
Which one are you?
See, I guess I'm just a nothing.
Did you ever do the thing
where you had a bunch of people
you were dating at once time?
When I was younger, yeah.
I was like really into keep it open,
easy breezy, stop locking everything down,
stop, stop, stop.
I was like, more of a dude than a girl.
Yeah, not so much me,
no dude, no here.
I'm like a-
You're more of a girl than a dude.
I was more of a dude than a girl.
That explains everything that's going on right here.
(Drew and audience laughing)
I think, right?
I tried dating a bunch of people once
and I was so exhausted by it.
I just knew it's not for me.
The only thing I would think might be necessary
is to try and be sort of open, honest,
and upfront about it.
Like, keep it real.
'Cause here's the thing about women
that you need to know.
The minute we meet you,
we're thinking, are you the one?
So I think you could do a lot of people a favor
by saying, I'm not looking for the one.
You know what, women are still gonna go, I'll change you.
That's a lot of pressure.
We're lost causes.
Every woman I know does the same thing.
I know.
It's what we do.
You're right about that.
And guess what men love?
What.
Pressure.
Oh yeah, we love that.
Yeah, exactly.
All right, our next story,
some people protect their hearts, they do,
but others need to be protecting their password.
CNN reports that, get this,
one, two, three, four, five, six,
that continues to be one of the most used passwords online.
Also topping the list of popular passwords, password.
And I love you, which is sweet
unless you don't love hackers
rooting through your bank account.
Do you do that thing where you have nine different passwords
or do you have the same password for every account?
I have so many combinations
that unfortunately, I can't get in to any of my stuff.
No seriously, like I can't get in there.
And I don't have email, I got rid of it.
Sorry?
Yep.
You don't have email?
(mic drops)
I don't have email.
I am www@donteveremailme.com.
She's lost it.
(Drew and Ross laughing)
A long time ago.
(upbeat music)